aliens are real
uaps as they're now called have been
visiting the Earth for decades and the
government knows maybe welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel where science fiction seems to
becoming science fact
[Music]
is there life beyond our little blue
planet and how much does the government
know about it
on Wednesday the House of
Representatives committee had a hearing
and at that hearing there were three
guests those guests very calmly sat down
and answered questions from the
committee and basically sat there and
said that yes the Earth is being visited
by extraterrestrial life and the
government knows about it
science fiction is no longer science
fiction
Close Encounters of the Fourth Kind
that's an historical documentary
I'm sounding a little sarcastic here but
what you guys might not know and some of
you do is that before I did the
Sidetrack Channel I had a mystery and
conspiracy Channel and I talked about
aliens a lot and to be honest the last
five or six years has been quite
interesting where actually the senate
committee have really asked a lot of
questions about the UFO phenomena and
we've actually found out that the
government has been hiding a lot
so most of you saw the Tic Tac videos
that released during lockdown you know
there's a lot of jokes that went around
you know you know we were all locked
down all had covered the US government
admitted aliens were real and nobody
cared those were the questions a house
oversight subcommittee attempt to dance
answer Wednesday as they heard testimony
from a former Air Force intelligence
officer and two Navy veterans well a lot
of people did care the Tic Tac video the
speeds the video and the other UFO
videos that were released at the time
that the Pentagon said they didn't know
what they were
have been widely debunked at very least
a lot of people have tried very very
hard to debunk them lawmakers are
demanding to know what the Pentagon has
in its files on unidentified aerial
phenomena or uaps the government term
for UFOs CBS News Scott McFarland
reports from Capitol Hill telling us
that these unusual orbs and things are
actually just other aircraft that
they're not to be you know concerned
about that they're nothing and basically
ignore what the pilots say because you
know they're just mistaken the evidence
is this and you shouldn't worry about it
now I am in two minds about that because
I generally firmly believe we should
follow evidence and act so having a
mystery and conspiracy Channel I can
actually tell you that the more you dig
into a lot of these stories that we know
so well the more you actually realize
that a lot of them are just not true
that unfortunately
the reality of a lot of UFO sightings is
really boring
but I can also tell you there are some
cases that I couldn't explain that
nobody that witnessed it could explain
and that have been investigated very
thoroughly and we can't explain
there are Mysteries out there the truth
is out there too
Alien films are a Hollywood staple so
perhaps no surprise the American people
deserve to know what is happening in our
skies there was a line out the door with
people anxious for the government to
share more about UFOs in the Baptist
Church we'd say that the devil's in our
way a Former Intelligence officer David
grush testified he suspects the
pentagon's unidentified aerial phenomena
or UAP office is covering up a
decades-long program to retrieve crashed
objects and all of a sudden the Senators
are particularly at this Committee
hearing seem to be trying hard to find
out what it is so who was at the senate
committee hearings and should we be
taking them seriously well David grush
was an ex-intelligence analyst and he
became a whistleblower he actually ran a
team for the Department of Defense until
2003. now the Pentagon have said that
his claims are false but he has said
that even though he's not seen any
aliens or UFOs or partial spacecraft or
anything himself do you believe that our
government is in possession of uaps uh
absolutely based on interviewing uh over
40 Witnesses over four years the
Pentagon has denied grush's claims two
former military Pilots also recounted
their Close Encounters this object was
estimated to be almost the size of a
football field former military pilot
David fraver testified he was astonished
by what he saw in the sky I think it's
far beyond actually our Material Science
that we currently possess he has spoken
to 40 or more people that have he has
conducted thorough interviews and become
convinced that the U.S government is
actually hiding a program that its sole
purpose is to recover either partial or
entire alien spacecrafts and that
they've been doing it for decades
Congress signaled It'll ask federal
agencies and the Pentagon to be more
transparent many people believe that
we're withholding information from them
on any unexplained aerial phenomena
incidents of which there have been at
least 366 reported since early 2021. do
you think anybody's mind was changed
because of this I think they will when
they say this they see those men they're
not just just some random people off the
street
now he actually didn't say an awful lot
in the Committee hearing but the
Committee hearing wasn't open to the
public hearing there were lots and lots
of people there desperately waiting to
see it if you actually look across the
front row and you're a bit of a UFO fan
you'll recognize a few of the faces
these hearings though do give a lot of
legitimacy to what he's saying even
though he did sit there and say quite a
lot I can't answer that question because
that information is still classified and
I'd really quite like not to go to
prison please he was able to say a lot
of things and he was very careful in his
answers that sometimes the senator would
try to ask the question a different way
and he would answer it a different way
giving us the information that we have
to read between the lines a little bit
but not giving so much information he
wasn't arrested the sooner he walked out
the door and Scott McFarland joins me
now Scott I'm going to save the question
I want to ask you first to my second
question so I'm going to ask you the
first question which is lawmakers really
said this was about National Security
can you help us understand their
argument in those terms
there's been a consistent argument from
both parties that if you have mysterious
items in the sky they are of nothing
else a danger to military aircraft in
the sky and potentially a danger to U.S
security below there was this parallel
pair of arguments today that either
these things are foreign objects from
other countries to spy on us or to get
near us which is a national security
issue or we don't know what these things
are which is a national security issue
listen to this exchange early during the
hearing between a Wisconsin congressman
and the witness at the witness table
do you believe uaps pose a Potential
Threat to our national security
yes the the technology that we faced was
far superior than anything that we had
identifying friend from foe is very
important to us and so when we have
unidentified targets and we continue to
ignore those due to a stigma or fear of
what it could be that's an opening that
our adversaries can take advantage of
the two other people in the hearing were
David fraver and Ryan Grace now David
fravor in particular is a personal
answer there's always very much
interested me
he's appeared on Joe Rogan he's appeared
on other things over the years and he
was really the pilot that kicked off the
Nimitz incident The Tick Tock video that
the Pentagon have never been able to
identify so it's that very famous video
that we've all seen with the object and
they're playing about it and you can
hear the voices oh my God there's a
whole Fleet of them blah blah now he
wasn't one of the pilots that actually
recorded that film what he did was he
went out he said that there was an
object that had dropped 80 000 feet in a
second and he was ordered to go and
identify it him with another aircraft
went and did that and they ended up
flying around this Tic Tac object for
several minutes they said it did
Maneuvers that were physically
impossible that they have technology
that is Way Beyond the means of anything
we have that mechanically and from a
materialistic point of view it was doing
things that just were not possible
he then told somebody else what had
happened and then when they went on
their mission they recorded what we then
saw that video then got leaked about 10
years later this happened apparently in
2004 we didn't see the videos until
2020. one connective tissue between all
these Witnesses and the members of
Congress on the Deus John they're all
arguing that the Public's on their side
that there's this tonnage of Americans
who want more information want the
government to open their books more they
think public sympathy or public opinion
is sympathetic to them he was also
joined by Ryan Graves now Ryan Graves
like fraver were both military pilots
and they both talked about how
seeing objects by other Pilots had
become regular that there was a massive
stigma and that actually your job is at
risk if you reported it sometimes but
that it was commonplace if you get
genuine Pilots out there that are
selling these things and that most
importantly don't change their story
that is a big thing for me researching a
lot of UFO instance over the years you
can almost tell the nonsense ones
because the eyewitnesses
best story changes over years people
listen to the story and they're amazed
and then they're not so amazed when they
get told it the third time so all of a
sudden the eyewitness remembers
something else and people are amazed
again and take interest in them fraver
and Ryan Graves have never done that
that I'm aware of their stories stayed
consistent
so this is the question I want to know
was there a stop the press this moment
was there and you sort of got at this at
the last in the final question of your
piece but um you know where where people
thought oh wow that's something new or
because it sounds like a lot of claims
things seen reports and so forth but
we've heard that before
a lot of this had the aura and feel and
dialogue of overnight AM radio and the
types of talk you hear
down at the dial late at night where
there's a lot of theories a lot of I
heard this I heard that this guy saw
this this guy saw that I'll tell you
what jumped out of Me John
there was a line Round the Bend to get
into this room today to put it mildly
Congress is not a Taylor Swift concert
they don't put on much of a show here it
was as if these people in line thought
Alf himself was going to be up on the
Deus and there'd be a spectacle to enjoy
that does speak to something though more
serious there is public interest in this
issue and these members of Congress are
good at two things at identifying an
issue the people will talk about and
minding the interests of their
constituents and I believe they think
they hit a sweet spot with their
constituents with this hearing today one
of the things Ryan Graves talked about
and that David fravor agreed with
actually is that there is a big problem
here at the moment that because there
are so many of these unidentified flying
objects these uaps as well that actually
it means there's a high risk of even if
these objects might not be a risk of
National Security the problem is that
because they start ignoring these uaps
something that is genuinely a risk might
slip through now we know the Chinese
have been trying to spy on the Americans
they've been doing that balloon thing
they did not long ago and other ways so
what he's basically saying is look we
don't think these aliens are a threat
but we do think possibly something else
might get through because we're chasing
these things or ignoring them because we
think it's one of these uaps so what
happens what happens next in and what do
they want to do with this information
from today
one short-term thing one long-term thing
even before this hearing began the U.S
Senate is seriously considering an
amendment to a must-pass piece of
legislation they're debating this week
that would require the National Archives
to release periodically government
reports on UFOs to make the information
accessible and digestible to the public
longer term goals a lot of house members
walked out of that hearing and told me
they're thinking about their own pieces
of legislation to require more
transparency in the federal government
John you know from all these years we've
been doing this that is an interesting
way of looking at it and the only way a
soldier basically would look at it the
ministry of Defense actually had to
release a statement about this a few
years ago over here in the UK and they
actually said yes we do look into some
of these unidentified fine objects when
they're reported to us but they are not
a risk International Security now that's
not a denial that's not them saying UFOs
and uaps don't exist and the aliens
aren't invaded in our airspace all
they're saying is they're not a risk do
they know something we don't know
just loves to argue that the federal
agencies need to be more transparent
more open with information they have
found yet another platform in which to
make that argument yes indeed they do
Scott McFarland on Capitol Hill thanks a
lot Scott
so is science fiction quickly becoming
science fact David grush even said that
there was a non-human beings discovered
in some of these alien vessels and that
we have those alien beings
so the movie poll is actually true
and
maybe he's a stoner too I don't know but
look
I might be a little bit sarcastic about
this and I might poke fun of it a little
bit just like they do in the news report
that I've been running through this
video
but actually this is something that we
need to look into properly the American
government has had to admit that over
the last several decades they have had
different programs to look into to try
and identify and to try to track unknown
alien vessels in our sky and by that I
mean just
unidentified flying objects not
necessarily E.T
they the interesting part about that is
though they denied it for decades
Operation Blue book is quite a famous
research project
they basically said that was the last
time we ever did it and that was back in
the 60s but it turns out they never
stopped why is the Department of Defense
and the Pentagon in the United States
spending so much money on This research
if there's nothing to it
they do need to start being a little bit
more honest and if there is something
out there we actually should know we can
take it
so just tell us and if there isn't
prove it so that we can stop talking
about it guys I'd love to know what you
think about these Congressional hearings
and the government basically
legitimizing these people by bringing
them in and talking to them like this we
do get people like Dr Steve agria which
I
I'm very much in two minds about that he
has done some brilliant work for the UFO
Community but he is also
been a bit of a con map and actually
made a very nice living out of also
being a bit of a con man
but these guys aren't doing that
so does legitimizing these people actual
professionals people are actually there
doing the work meaning that the
government and the senate committee at
very least is starting to take them a
little bit more seriously or is it more
likely that there are political reasons
why they're doing it
to be honest
I wouldn't be surprised if there were
get in the comments though and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and normally we do talk about
just science fiction
but seeing that you know it's becoming
fact now I thought it was worth talking
about
also though you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos Drop first and you get to
see them without the adverts for a small
contribution each month that really
helps out the channel
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign